jetzt bei achtung verhandlungen
das war die stimme des kleinen tristan
am 26 märz 1998 wurde er auf
bestialische weise in frankfurt ermordet
der täter fiel in einem tunnel über ihn
her wirkte erstach und verstümmelte ihn
bis heute ist kein vergleichbarer fall
bekannt und bis heute ist der mörder
nicht ermittelt aber es gibt das
phantombild eines verdächtigen dieses
hier und damit suchen wir uns sucht die
polizei hier beachtung verhandlungen
gleich nach dem täter
am 26 märz 1998 finden kinder in einem
tunnel in frankfurt die verstümmelte
leiche eines jungen es ist der kleine
tristan er wurde bewusstlos geschlagen
gewürgt und erstochen das verbrechen
schockiert damals ganz deutschland auch
bei der mörder bis heute nicht gefasst
wurde aber es gibt spuren tristans
rucksack mit einer deutschlandkarte in
tschechischer sprache ein fingerabdruck
auf tristan schulheft und das
phantombild eines verdächtigen
kräutergärtner mit den wichtigen
recherchen
tristan brübach 13 jahre alt ein
introvertierter hübscher junger ein kind
dass tiere liebt und das in jungen
jahren schon viel leid erfahren hat denn
tristans mutter begeht 1995 selbstmord
tristan wächst bei seinem vater bernd
auf
und am 26 märz 1998 wird tristan in
frankfurt am main opfer eines
bestialischen verbrechen
das ist einfach irgendwie krank von der
person die das gemacht hat und warum er
das gemacht hat das wissen wir nicht
[Musik]
ja das war schon
wirklich schlimm
in diesem tunnel nur wenige hundert
meter von seinem zuhause entfernt wird
tristan brübach grausam ermordet ein
schock für alle die dem jungen nahe
standen dann haben mich eltern angerufen
und bekannte und haben gesagt du herr
maße denn gehört das ist ja dein tristan
das war natürlich ganz furchtbar ganz
furchtbar ja das denke ich heute oft
noch dran diese zeit hier haben die
mütter ihre kinder bewacht denn tristan
wird nicht nur ermordet sondern auch
verstümmelt erinnert sich constantinis
damals als junger rechtsmedizinerin am
tatort im einsatz
das wurden entfernt wurden und auch
wurden mitgenommen nicht mehr nicht mehr
wiedergefunden wurden
ist eigentlich schon also ein akt großer
brutalität
der jetzt ein leben beendet hat der
tatort der liederbach tonne in
frankfurt-höchst ein unheimlicher
dunkler ort 112 meter lang damals noch
offen eine fußgängerunterführung
warum war tristan hier traf er dort
seinen mörder war es ein
sexualverbrechen
das ist durchaus im bereich des
möglichen dass dass der täter sich das
sexuelle befriedigung gesucht und auch
gefunden hat
und daher kann man es nicht gänzlich
ausschließen könnte so tristans mörder
aussehen und was hat der verstorbene
serienmörder manfred seel mit dem fall
zu tun oder christian b der
tatverdächtige im fall maddie warum gibt
es bis heute keinen fahndungserfolg
reporter kolja gärtner erinnert sich
noch genau an den fall die bild zeitung
berichtet seit anbeginn über tristan und
die suche nach seinem mörder
tristan im tunnel wartete der mörder
führt ein stück klebefolie jetzt zu
tristans mörder
neue hoffnung im mordfall tristan
das verbrechen an tristan ist jetzt 23
jahre her
weil es so abartig war ist es immer noch
sehr präsent beschäftigt die menschen
mich beschäftigt auch persönlich weil
ich vom ersten tag an dabei war und dann
auch viele jahre hier gewohnt hat ein
paar hundert meter weiter und man denkt
immer der typ läuft hier wahrscheinlich
noch rum
der junge auf dem anrufbeantworter wird
am dritten oktober 1984 geboren ein
fröhliches kind doch tristan hat keine
leichte kindheit seine mutter leidet an
depressionen begeht drei jahre vor
seiner ermordung suizid dass ich meinen
klar wenn wenn wenn man seine mutter
verliert egal wie nah das ist schlimm
und es war für ihn auch schlimm
tristan lernt früh selbstständig zu sein
er verbringt viel zeit alleine nimmt
wegen lerndefiziten teil am
förderunterricht von maria haas gerade
als genommen haben haben wir manchmal so
ba sich halbwegs sagte sind blonde engel
er hat die blonden haare war sehr
zierlich und
hochintelligent aber mit der zeit wurde
schon immer introvertierte vor allem
nach dem selbstmord seiner mutter wird
die veränderung deutlich
er wurde hatte und dieses kindliche
was früher so süß war mich immer fast
sagen so als klein als kleiner junge
kleinere junge das ist verloren gegangen
es kam eine gewisse härte und deswegen
kam es auch immer wieder zu streit auf
einem schulhof
auch christians vater bernd belastet der
verlust seiner frau der vater hat halt
ein alkoholproblem gehabt es hieß er hat
hätte auch ein drogenproblem das kann
ich natürlich nichts sagen das weiß ich
nicht aber er hatte ein alkoholproblem
sucht tristan woanders zuneigung gerät
er dabei an die falschen leute menschen
die ihn ausnutzen
[Musik]
frankfurt-höchst sechsundzwanzigster
märz 1998 unweit von zu hause wird
tristan getötet einer der brutalsten
mordfälle deutschlands wir sind hier am
liederbach tunnel der unter den gleisen
des bahnhofs höchst durchführt hier
unten und hier wurde tristan ermordet
und verstümmelt was ist hier passiert
die ermittler haben tristans letzte wege
durch zeugenaussagen genauestens
analysiert demnach rief christen gegen
acht uhr morgens von einer telefonzelle
seinen vater an klagte über
rückenschmerzen
ungefähr eine minute lang zeigen
aufnahmen einer überwachungskamera von
dem zeitschriftenladen auf der anderen
seite der bahnhofshalle es sind die
letzten bilder dieses von tristan gibt
er lässt sich vom vater überreden geht
trotz schmerzen zur schule in die
meisterschule in sindlingen er verlässt
sie allerdings frühzeitig gegen 13.30
und sagt seiner lehrerin er wurde zum
arzt
hier ist tristan dann von der schule zur
bushaltestelle gegangen es gegen 14 uhr
noch gesehen worden wie er in einem bus
richtung bahnhof höchst gestiegen ist
auch im bus wird tristan noch von zeugen
erkannt kommt schließlich am bahnhof an
und läuft richtung bruno asch anlage
gegen 15 und 20 wird er hier das letzte
mal gesehen wie er eine zigarette raucht
und den hund einer zeugin streichelt
[Musik]
von der bruno asch anlage kommt endete
hier nach ungefähr 400 metern
wahrscheinlich der letzte weg von
tristan unten hier im liederbach tunnel
traf er auf seinen mörder dieser tunnel
wurde gerne von kindern und jugendlichen
als abkürzung auf die andere seite der
bahngleise genutzt die polizei vermutet
dass kinder zeugen der grausamen tat
wurden pakistan ein zufallsopfer hat der
täter in einem bereich in dem viele
kinder waren ein opfer gesucht also im
eingangsbereich zu dem tunnel waren
haben sie eine person wahrgenommen die
ihr angaben zufolge über einen
gegenstand auf der betonsockel gebeugt
waren dass das cabrio ja etwas
unheimlich vor sie haben sich
entschieden dann doch den längeren weg
in kauf zu nehmen und im nachgang muss
man sagen dass die drei jugendlichen
wahrscheinlich den täter gerade weil
tatausführung beobachtet haben ohne die
tat als solche erkannt zu haben
spielende kinder vom jugendzentrum
gegenüber die die unterführung nutzen
wollen finden gegen 16 uhr tristans
leiche die kinder alarmieren ihre
betreuer doch keiner glaubt ihnen erst
um 17 uhr 8 geht der notruf einer
betreuerin bei der polizei ein den
ermittlern bietet sich ein bild des
grauens
rechtsmedizinerin constantinis ist
damals als junge assistentin am tatort
[Musik]
aber was mir so wie es in den erinnerung
geblieben ist dass es dunkel war und es
war kalt und ich glaube es war auch es
war feucht das war die stimmung dort
wurde eben berichtet dass es
verletzungen am hals gegeben hat eine
schnittverletzung am hals und das auch
körperteile entfernt worden sind die
hoden seien entfernt worden und das ist
auch hinweise dafür gegeben hat dass
eine andersartige als diese
schnittverletzung eine gewalt gegen den
hals stattgefunden hat in form einer
kompression
der täter schlägt und würgt tristan
bewusstlos er schneidet ihm die kehle
durch lässt den leichnam in bach
ausbilden dann legte er ihn auf dem
betonsockel ab und nimmt ihm beide hoden
und entfernt am gesäß und an der
rückseite eines oberschenkels große
teile muskelfleisch die leichenteile
wurden bis heute nicht gefunden
polizeipräsidium frankfurt am main hier
lagern über 20.000 hinweise zum mordfall
tristan kam er am bahnhof in kontakt mit
personen des kriminellen milieus mit
pädophilen war er aufgrund seiner
familiensituation leicht zu manipulieren
indem ersten ermittlungsschritt und ging
davon aus oder die haben es gezeigt dass
tristan sein mörder gekannt haben muss
hat
sich der täter ein männliches kindliches
opfer gesucht um seine fantasien zu
befriedigen
ich denke der tristan hat nähe gesucht
die ihr dann vielleicht durch seine
familie nicht bekommen hat und hat sich
dann wenn jemand angeschlossen weil er
dachte dass die vertrauenspersonen dem
kann ich mich anschließen
noch am tag tristans mordes wird eine
soko mit über 100 beamten eingerichtet
zur spurensuche wurde der bach
ausgepumpt spürhunde metalldetektoren
und sonden eingesetzt unter tristan
schulsachen fand man im bach den bis
heute wichtigsten hinweis man hat auf
dem schulhof teuren fingerabdruck
gefunden das hatte uns ja auch dann in
2012 noch mal dazu veranlasst eine große
rollen untersuchung von fingerabdrücken
durchzuführen über 14.000 männer aus den
umliegenden frankfurter stadtteilen
werden überprüft ein in deutschland noch
nie dagewesene aufwand jedoch ohne
erfolg doch die ermittler geben nicht
auf
wir haben in alle richtungen ermittelt
da gehört natürlich auch
das dazu dass man mal in psychiatrien
schaut sitzen dort leute ein dass man
bei sexualstraftätern schaut also da
wurde die ganze bandbreite überprüft und
abgedeckt einen monat nach der tat kommt
bewegung in den fall jemand gesteht
telefone stehen wird
[Musik]
doch als die polizei am bahnhof ankommt
gibt es keine spur vom anrufer über eine
hotline war der anruf bundesweit
abrufbar doch bis heute konnte niemand
ermittelt werden ein jahr später die
nächste heiße spur in einem waldstück
bei niedernhausen etwa 25 kilometer vom
tatort entfernt findet man tristans
bislang verschollenen rucksack inklusive
einer tschechischen deutschlandkarte
führt sie zum täter
tristan brübach aus frankfurt wer hat
ihn am 26 märz 1998 bestialisch ermordet
im bach ausbluten lassen und im
liederbach tunnel an dem 13-jährigen die
hoden und muskelfleisch entnommen
schon längere zeit dort einfach
unendlich lang nur so eine spur des
rucksackes noch mal viele
ermittlungsansätze erhofft aber leider
auch die haben nicht zum ziel geführt
den täter identifizieren zu können im
rucksack finden die ermittler eine
tschechische deutschlandkarte kommt der
täter aus dem tschechien doch auch die
karte führt bis heute zu keinem ergebnis
eineinhalb jahre später herz 99 erregt
der fall erneut aufsehen jemand versucht
sich zugang zu tristan sagt zu
verschaffen war es der täter gibt es die
unterschiedlichsten gründe einer
fleischwunde nochmal die tat durch leben
möchte ja amt war vielleicht auch weil
er reue hat und sich entschuldigen
möchte auch da ist die bandbreite sehr
sehr groß
doch auch diese spur führt ins nichts
2006 werden die zeugenaussagen erneut
auf parallelen geprüft und es fällt
etwas auf an unterschiedlichen orten oft
in verbindung zu kindern wollen zeugen
einen mann beobachtet haben 2008
entsteht endlich ein phantombild des
mörders
175 groß 20 bis 30 jahre alt mit narbe
an der oberlippe und pferdeschwanz
[Musik]
dieses bild ist aber für sie immer noch
auf das aktuelle was auch immer noch
verwendet wird um
vielleicht dem täter doch noch auf die
spur zu kommen ja da braucht es noch
also dass das bild von dem immer noch
ausgehen auch tristans ehemalige
nachhilfelehrerin maria haas will einen
mann mit diesem aussehen gemeinsam mit
tristan in der nähe ihres büros bemerkt
haben und dann habe ich aus dem fenster
geschaut und gesehen dass tristan dort
läuft mit einem mann der mir unbekannt
war und das sind dann anschließend
herunter gegangen und hat den hintern
der haben kündigt an der straße da sind
ab sonntag verlor es gibt ja dieses
phantombild richtig ja
sie sagen der war wirklich auch ähnlich
ja ja ich würde sagen so wie es gesehen
habe
hätte etwas sagen kann hat er nicht ich
hatte kein also wenn ich ein schlechtes
gefühl gehabt hätte wäre ich hinten
schauen gegangen das hatte ich nicht ich
habe in tristan gesehen mit diesem mann
mit seinem ranzen aber ich habe mir
einfach damals nichts dabei gedacht also
ich befürchte dass das jemand war den
erkannte zudem mehr vertrauen hatte
dabei vertraut hat
doch trotz der zeugen führt auch das
phantombild bislang nicht zum täter der
fall tristan brübach wird zum cold case
gegen das vergessen der grausamen tat an
tristan stemmen sich nicht nur die
ermittler sondern auch ehemalige freunde
der familie gruber
[Musik]
also mord verjährt ja nicht ja also das
ist von daher bleibt es immer so in
gedanken man vergisst es nicht also ich
vergesse es nicht
tristans vater bernd wird die aufklärung
des mordes nicht mehr miterleben kurz
vor seinem tod bittet er in einem
spiegel tv interview darum dass mögliche
zeugen sich melden
aus mein erstes sollte man halt sofort
die polizei informieren
dass es probleme gibt wie seine nachbarn
oder bekannten den schlechten ruf zu
bringen ist mir vollkommen klar nur
es muss ja kein diebstahl
er stirbt 2014 als gebrochener mann er
erlebt noch wie im taunus ein verbrechen
entdeckt wird so grausam dass es an
tristan erinnert der verstorbene rentner
manfred seel hat in seiner garage fässer
mit leichenteilen einer frau verwahrt
die er 2003 ermordet hat sammelte er
auch tristans körperteile natürlich
haben wir dann auch noch mal geschaut ob
es irgendwo parallelen gibt aber auch da
haben die ermittlungen keinen dringenden
tatverdacht ergeben sodass eigentlich
auch als täter auszuschließen ist selbst
ein fingerabdruck wurde von selig nahm
genommen und mit dem von tristan
schulheft verglichen doch wieder kein
treffer
2020 macht erneut eine spur schlagzeilen
die staatsanwaltschaft prüft
verbindungen zwischen tristans fall und
dem fall maddie der sexualverbrecher
christian b sieht dem phantombild
tristans verblüffend ähnlich doch die
ermittlungen bleiben bislang ohne
ergebnis
die polizei fragt wer hat am 26 märz
1998 etwas verdächtiges gesehen an
tristan schule dem bahnhof höchst in der
bruno asch parkanlage oder am liederbach
tunnel
wer kannte tristan mit wem hat ihr
umgang wir hoffen da hat kassel ist dass
ich noch irgendjemanden war meldet der
sagt ich habe ein geistesblitz das habe
ich irgendwie über die ganzen jahre
vergessen dass er sich einfach noch mal
loswerden will wer kennt diesen mann
oder hat jemand auffälliges im umfeld
von kindern gesehen wer hat jemanden als
täter im verdacht wer kennt jemanden der
am 26 märz 98 durchnässte oder
blutbefleckte kleidung trug
ja ich würde mir ganz ganz arg wünschen
dass derjenige gefasst wird also dass
man damit abschließen kann nicht nur für
mich sondern hält auch für für tristan
für die leute die tristan kannten jeder
will dass der täter endlich bestraft
wird ich wünsche mir wie alle menschen
glaube ich in frankfurt in deutschland
dass dieser fall endlich geklärt wird
dass es dem einen entscheidenden hinweis
nach den tausenden die es bisher gab
letztendlich gibt der zum täter führt
helfen sie den fall tristan brübach
endlich aufzuklären hinweise an 0 69 75
wirklich erschüttern der fall über den
wir noch ein bisschen weiter sprechen
wollen hier im studio mit dr
constantinis die bei uns ist haben sich
auch gerade im beitrag gesehen
rechtsmedizinerin guten abend und
professor christian matz tor viele jahre
kripo ermittler auch einen guten abend
frauen ist wir haben gerade gesehen sie
waren damals am tatort wenn sie uns dann
noch einmal mit hin nehmen und sie haben
ihren tatort koffer mitgebracht was sind
denn an so einem ort des verbrechens
überhaupt die ersten schritte was machen
sie da ja wir werden also vorab
eingeführte treffen uns mit den beamten
die vor ort sind und kriegen eine ganz
kurze erläuterung und dann nähern wir
uns der szene das war jetzt in diesem
fall diese tunnel in dem man durchaus an
gemähte reihen laufen musste es war
recht finster soir 19 uhr oder etwas
später als wir ankamen war zwar
beleuchtet aber es war insgesamt nicht
nur eine finstere stimmung es war auch
eine finstere umgebung und da haben wir
dann den jungen gesehen man hat ja beim
bei im beitrag auch schon erkennen
können dass ein so ein beton artiger
vorsprung der war auf der linken seite
der nieder bach und auf der anderen
seite neben diesen kleinen gang dem
rhein laufen konnte und dort lag dann
dieser junge bäuchlings auf dieser
diesem beton vorsprung und was wir
machen dass wir praktisch die diese
erste szene
ein augenschein nehmen nun einfach nur
beschreiben die szene auch auf uns
wirken lassen und ganz direkt da
hingehen und hand anlegen und ja da mal
zu sehen dass er eben teil begleitet
gewesen ist dass das gesicht zur seite
gedreht war man konnte auf den rücken
blicken und eben auf die schon
freiliegenden verletzungen da wir sie
einmal fragen was sie an geriet dann in
so einer situation dabei haben also was
ist in ihrem tatort kauf hat dann dabei
also neben der feststellung ob sich so
ein gewaltverbrechen handelt oder nicht
ist eines der wichtigen sachen die wir
unternehmen müssen die todeszeit
feststellung und die müssen wir
möglichst zeitnah an unsere befunde
sammeln das ist zum beispiel wie wir in
unserem tatort koffer dann drin haben
die temperaturmessung mit so einem gerät
das man dann eben entsprechende einführt
um die tiefe körper temperatur zu messen
die war im fall von trips dann waren es
gerade mal 23 grad was uns dann sagt
dass er schon eine ganze weile da
gelegen hat herr professor matzdorf das
sind ja unglaubliche verstümmelungen die
da an dem kind vorgenommen wurden was
sagt ihnen das über den täter typ aus
also dieser fall lag natürlich dadurch
über andere tötungsdelikte hinaus dass
der körper teilen worden sind das
fleisch herausgeschnitten worden das
unterstrich sehr dafür dass wir mit
einem täter zu tun haben der etwas
braucht was ihm sozusagen die tat
weiterleben lässt also er nimmt etwas
mit das kann eine trophäe sein das kann
ein anreiz sein der vielleicht sogar zur
sexuellen erregung führt oder aber
einfach gegen die möglichkeit gibt
kontrolle zu haben also weitere tat
hinaus noch kontrolle zu haben indem man
diese körperteile mitnimmt und das ist
schon eine ganz besondere
täter persönlichkeit die solche taten
begehen kann einmal die tötung an sich
und dann eben diese besondere form der
behandlung des toten jungen sprechen
diese besonderen umstände dafür dass es
ein einzelfall war oder dass es hier um
einen täter geht der so was womöglich
schon mehrfach getan hat es ist aus
kriminalistischer erfahrung wird auch
vor dem hintergrund chronologisch
erkenntnisse er als einen segen tat
einzuordnen also ich würde nicht davon
ausgehen dass sich um einen einzelfall
handelt denn es gehört ja etwas dazu
eine entwicklung bis man zu diesem punkt
kommt eine tat derartig zu beginn in
dieser form auch mit einer gewissen
perfektionierung was das heraustrennen
der körperteile angeht und da könnte man
eher mutmaßen dass er sich um eine
serien tat handelt und es schon weitere
taten im vorfeld gegeben hat die durch
diesen täter verübt worden sind hinter
ihnen beiden sehen wir dieses
phantombild was sozusagen ja die
wichtigste spur in dem ganzen fall heute
ist das ist nun nach vielen jahren
entstanden dieses phantombild wie
entsteht eigentlich heute noch so ein
phantombild und wie ja sicher ist diese
spur wie sehr kann man sich auf dieses
bild verlassen
schwierige frage denn diejenigen die
dazu beitragen dass ein phantombild sich
entwickeln kann das praktisch ihre
aussagen machen und dann dieses
phantombild weiter gestalten sodass der
realität nahe kommen kann die haben
natürlich erinnerungen die er überlagert
sind da muss man gewisse vorsicht walten
lassen auf der einen seite auf der
anderen seite gibt es natürlich dinge
die sich menschen besonders einbringen
besonders merken und die halten sich
sehr lange im gedächtnis und die können
dann dann ist gut umgesetzt wird ein
phantombild auch sehr ähnlich machen und
auch sehr zutreffend dann die täter
beschreiben ponys ist der fall tristan
so ein fall der sie nicht loslässt ich
habe auch gesehen wie sie im beitrag
gesehen haben kommen der alte bilder
nochmal hoch
definitiv ja also das ist im fall den
habe ich so noch nie gesehen die ganze
komplexität von den verletzungen die wir
festgestellt haben ist sicherlich selten
bis einmaliger sind an unserem institut
ist sowas noch nicht vorgekommen und
auch am hellichten tage und in so kurzer
zeit wie es scheint das zeitfenster ist
nicht lange und bei so einem kleinen
kind das ist schon ungewöhnlich
ponys und hermannsdorf in vielen dank
dass sie heute bei uns war für sie noch
einen schönen abend danke
ja und der fall tristan
bis heute gibt es eben in deutschland
keinen vergleichbaren fall und vor allem
ist bis heute der mörder nicht ermittelt
wenn sie doch noch etwas wissen dann
melden sie sich bei der polizei
frankfurt unter 069 75 55 11 08 und für
sachdienliche hinweise ist eine
belohnung von insgesamt 20.000 euro
ausgelöst